welcome back everybody we're gonna
assign me to take over his job I'm
introducing Wolfgang Moss who is it I
mean the information is right here and
I'll need to read it
Wolfgang is kind of a so split brain
between computer science and with the
strong interest in neuroscience that's
been working on kind of a roll
neroli inspired network models for a
long time liquid state machines spiking
networks this kind of thing so without
further ado let me introduce walking
[Applause]
yeah I was trained as a theater computer
scientist here actually by man rod Blum
and the captain a while ago and my job
would have been much easier we wouldn't
have been exposed to this previous talks
by padlet and yesterday at least man
could try to make our jobs for computer
scientists much easier much much more
difficult and I def I want to start here
with know kind of the natural results
which the theater computer scientist
would probably aim at know when they
look at network of spiking neurons and
then address you know all these
obstacles which have been thrown out
there and even add another one which
hasn't even been mentioned and thoughts
the end I also want to discuss briefly a
little bit mythological issues because I
think know as a science nor theater
computation neuroscience has to reflect
a little bit about its methods and
validate its methods and then I use
actually as a pretty consistent color
you know red for kind of clues
constraints monkey wrenches which are
thrown into our machinery Authority
shion's and a reserve blue for open
problems so will be quite a bit of blue
out there and so this hopefully gives
also experts something to think about
where they're duly bored by the rest of
the talk
so we have seen spike in neurons I think
I don't have to go really into this and
then no address this question which has
been addressed by hundreds perhaps
thousands of different papers how can
running code information with spikes and
so a padlet now talked about this rate
coding ideas so that know if you have
you know ten ruins so this is time then
each of them has a certain rate but
whence these are a little bit the
difficulty in think in terms of rate
coding because this is almost realistic
variability of in the spike intervals
there and so on see you just to simpler
estimate the rate you need to have a
long enough time window but the rate
tends to change already during this time
window so this is a somewhat problematic
no approach then but still certainly
valid then there is an interesting
approach nor for encoding information
with single spikes if you have some
background clock like an oscillation
which actually do have in or some areas
of the hippocampus know quite
prominently then you can also encode
information in the face of a single
spike relative to this background
oscillation then traditionally also know
people had considered other courts know
like ants in fire chain they have no
kind of large population events at a
certain time I think they have been
somewhat falling out of favor because
it's harder to do powerful computations
with them then one kind of code which
has been considered also know
particularly by semeth operand roofin is
a thing here know that when things know
if you get for some central input comes
in and the neuron that fires first maybe
has to say the most important
information about this input and so it's
a kind of no timing code without a clock
just know relative to the stimulus so
that the first spikes count more than
the latest spikes in this competition
for spiking them and even us no doubt
just the question of with regard to any
of these codes what is the theory of
your computational power of a network of
spiking neurons when sees actually
no this theory computation power is
quite large so we can easily construct
this net for the spike neurons that can
simulate any Turing machine even the
universal Turing machine and you also
can show that in F of spiking neurons
can simulate with single spikes
artificial moon output an artificial
neural network and a feed-forward
artificial neural network and I want to
sketch though this easy ideas no boots
on are over 20 years old
serve on assumes know that you have
epsps have some linear initial segments
so their rise here or if an IPS p no
they go down with a certain slope which
is no defiance debate and this happens
to be just accidentally actually very
how usually neurophysiologist measure no
debate of a synapse no they look at the
slope of the rising part of the eps
speed and but this is just accidentally
so here even assumes now that input to
neurons is given then in terms of the
timing of spikes so that you know this
is one neuron which fired know very
early then so it represents like a large
output analog output of a sigmoid and
ruin of the preceding layer then so this
starts earlier to rise here then right
and whereas one which no fires later no
then represents a smaller output but in
this case no there's a larger of wait
then and so in the end if you then have
a neuron you know which receives all
this no epsps which start at different
time points and then you'll consider a
threshold then one can see that this
really carries out a weighted sum of
this kind of delay codes here then and
so therefore you can now if you have now
here say feed-forward neural network
with what is your seven different layers
you can represent the parallel
computation of each layer simply in
terms of the relative firing of each
neuron then and so the computation
computation from one layer to the next
layer uses the simple ideas here then
someone can use also know the same
coding idea to encode in the kind of
know relative timing of spikes no any
pit vector now if you assume there's no
noise then you can encode the any
rational number so kind of a binary
number and so the whole content of a
Turing machine can become encoded in
this then and in this way you can also
construct networks of spiking neurons
that can simulate a stick by simply no
kind of somewhat manipulating this delay
in order to push or pop one more bit
onto the stack then and so therefore in
the same way doing this at several
states in parallel you have already full
power of a Turing machine then so
therefore we see in principle no spiking
neurons computation powerful and I could
not finish my talk already at this point
if you wouldn't have a small issue with
noise and other things which I discussed
in the following and I think know what
the goal of my talks will be to address
these additional issues and see what
remains of theoretical models and
arguments so I still want to push for
theory and add models then but no Ellery
as Jeff Lichtman pointed out yesterday
we have seen a kind of a change of
phases in the last 20 years 20 years ago
they were not so powerful experimental
results but lots of good ideas and
theories how the brain works now we have
tons of data but not so many series and
even concepts nor to approach the
question how does the brain compute then
and I want to initiate here no
discussion in this direction then of
that first statement for understanding
the brain do you think it's a historical
statement I don't want to kind of know
defend this it's just just when you go
at this hair computer scientist into spy
network of spiking neurons this is one
thing you can prove and then let's ask
now what is the risk in this then and so
as I mentioned here in you know kind of
noise it's an issue I could even prove
theoretically any analog neural network
in particular also no such networks back
neurons which
no in encodes analog values with timing
of spikes drops down to that of a
deterministic finite automaton if you
have any no finite amount of noise that
it goes even lower if you have no kind
of Gaussian noise or so on the input and
so therefore the question is now is that
noise in valid signal networks or
Kuhlman argue there find ways of coping
business in principle no no computer
science is lots full of powerful ideas
how one can cope with noise and also
know get rid of noise and so we have to
see no but their brains have similar
opportunities so one of the first
features that was pointed out to me know
by experimental neuroscientists was
because Logothetis when I started to
collaborate with experimentalist was
know that they always find this try to
try variability in experiments so this
whatever you have an extra mint and you
try to reproduce the same experiment no
kind of you give the same stimulus right
try to reproduce the same initial state
of organism and then you find from it in
each trial assemble different spike
response then and as far as I have seen
or maybe some one of you can tell me
counter example the second space it here
in every experiment at every temporal
and spacial scale of measurements but so
therefore this try to try Vera but he
seems to be really a characteristic
feature of brain dynamics and therefore
also gives us how can brains compute
given this try to try burr ability just
is given here no same results we just
happen to have you know kind of slide is
no it was from visual cortex the cat was
in three trials showing the same visual
input pattern a and so this is no spike
trends of eight neurons and actually the
eight neurons contained full information
about what this input was but you see
from this trial to this trial it looks
completely different not only the timing
of spikes is off right now these spikes
no don't come up here and suddenly here
and trial three nor there come to have
spikes here then and here no this neuron
fired here now kind of periodically for
a while then and here not at all here's
something in between the
this is I think quite typical that not
only the timing of single spikes is no
varies from trial to trial but even the
number of spikes very strongly from
trial to trial and here now this is the
same for another input nor three trials
again you see even here kind of over
other rates here probably not twice as
large as here this one fires a lot here
but not for this and so therefore it's a
question of how can now a drown down
trim downstream system of area we won
then really the code Nova that was input
a or input B given the fact that the
difference between here and here is
almost as large as between here and here
then and so this is I think obviously a
problem for any inner computational
model and encoding idea now as I
mentioned know in theory or computer
science we are not so much worried about
noise because you can always there to
placate units and then take the average
duplicate noisy units or sub circuits
and then simply take the average of the
outputs right and this gives you good
approximation to the truth then but I
think no but we have seen early from
yesterday's talk from Jeff Lichtman but
also Anton's know data from the LM data
set is that no test application of
neurons or subsets seems to be something
which is apparently not really supported
by brains then so one hardly ever finds
two neurons which have the same input
output behavior
you also see when you even record from
zillions of neurons and kinds of imaging
you hardly ever see two neurons which
seem to do about the same thing know
that fire at the same point in time then
there's additional problem which no it
was even addressed then
then from as far as I can see from
published data you don't even find two
neurons which get exactly the same
inputs there so even though surprisingly
even pyramidal cells which are very
close together then appear to share on
the order of maximally
30% of their presynaptic neurons they're
the prison of the inputs so you don't
even have two neurons which get exactly
the same input and you could take the
average of the output now as a kind of
know the noise version of a computation
then so this suggests to me that this
strategy which we use in computer
science to get rid of noise in
computation system is not available to
brains then and therefore brains have to
cope a different base with noise then
and I think this is really one creation
we should address nor how can it cope
with noise or possibly even benefit from
noise one of the most surprising
features of no synapses was I think only
mentioned in passing if at all yesterday
is no Ben no this is now here synapse
now this is a presynaptic bouton this is
the postsynaptic density when the
synapse comes then here no vesicle is
released then it's neurotransmitter is
emitted in synaptic cleft it opens an
receptors and the postsynaptic side but
this doesn't happen all of us then so
actually no review paper suggests this
happens about 50% of the time so this
means 50% of the time and the spy comes
down here nothing happens the
postsynaptic side doesn't even know
about this presynaptic spike in addition
vesicles are released and then there's
no spike happening here so the
postsynaptic side gets a signal but the
presynaptic was nothing here so from
this perspective no synapses in the
neocortex are really lousy computational
units then and I find this quite amazing
because these are really the key points
we assume all know the valuable
information is really encode in synapses
right and now they have this very
strange feature some neuroscientists
argue that they find massamba newer
invertebrates also synapses which are
hundreds
reliable so that nature in principle can
be realized the synapse it's not a
defect of nature but no they argue
therefore that nature on purpose decided
to work with unreliable synapses and I
think we have to understand know why and
how one can make use of this there's
actually also one kind of no.11
possibility one sees actually if you
know you have you know point five is you
know kind of generic release probability
this allows actually neuron to somewhat
regulate also its impact on the post up
in Iran by simply increasing or
decreasing this release probability
right from this perspective no point
five is a good value actually okay
there's another remedy that is often
discussed for a low release probability
in an experiment like this where they
simply send one action potential you
know you know in a slice experimental
looking to see whether there was a
proposed synaptic potential which is
that there are people who believe that
the main signaling is through bursts
bursts of action potentials which will
lead to a much higher released on Billy
oh yeah we're more consistent response
so it could be that individual spikes
are meant to be ignored or not to have a
large effect than indication and the
signals of the brain actually wants to
send around almost always come in bursts
this is a good point yeah I'm not so bad
I see this in the data I have seen know
that almost all of us the information
comes in form of birth I think that they
buy some I think actually measurements
from the Sackman live there are good
fifteen percent of the spikes of li-fi
protocells come as part of a person so I
don't know it's 50 percent now a lot or
not and but I think we can maybe can
come back to this question later Libby
later where they talk about certain
plasticity of synapses because these are
then one tendency these are synapses
actually act in a special ways to person
and so this will be interesting possibly
also for computation series
questioning our girl seductions in the
ring where this is all right this was I
think this nor synapse I heard of yet
completely paranoid there despite this
dough is about one OK timing on a key of
micro second level is used to code okay
so this is that thank you so this is the
kind of note supports this no idea know
that nature can build reliable synapses
if it wants to although I think no
there's obviously limit if it just looks
at here the biophysics it can only
produce as many basic releases as there
kind of vesicles here actually in the
readily release on them right which is
limited now maybe few doesn't know it
doesn't so right now they sell limit
know kind of lots of spikes come at some
point it has to give up then right now
so this is kind of inherent simply in
this chemical synapse okay so this is
now a good point know that really
synapses produce noise then so therefore
I think man cannot argue that it's a
question whether there's noise in neural
system of course I don't want to get
into philosophy where this is not true
noise or whether they're hidden
variables somewhere here in this
molecular machinery right at the moment
I think from our perspective or the
network it doesn't make a difference but
I don't want to know insist on this
being true noise noise then right it
just appears to us noise these are
unknown variables so therefore the
question assuming now that production
neural networks really designed by
evolution to be noisy or at least I have
a large try to try the ability criminals
to say are there particular types of
computational models which can benefit
from this set up and certainly they are
then kind of no particulars you know
your computer science here in Berkeley
has really shown or stochastic
computation can do marvelous thing is
something credibly powerful and some
kind of a low dimensional projection is
no simply looking at no simple Markov
chain here which is something no here no
they indicated here you have a finite
number of states and then you have
transition probabilities like from this
state you can the third of this so the
three percent probability you transition
to this
state and another 33% probably to this
state or to this state and right and so
therefore when you turn it on or some
based on initial state you cruise around
in here then and so therefore the state
in which you are is something which
changes all the time but the exciting
thing is no there's something really
which is invariant for Markov chain
which is no station or distribution of
network states which defines for each
state at the long term fraction of time
in which this Markov chain spends in
this particular state and this is
independent of the initial state and
it's as you know Google now really made
quite a bit of been a quite a bit of
benefit from this no theorem then but
now so therefore since the question of
whether this could be used for
computations in biological neural
networks and I think I can also easily
come up no base
computational demands where these types
of computation sampling is useful then
for example the many kind of paradigms
for unsupervised every bought based
learning really require that you have
exploration there I will not probably
come to some examples then then no one
way of doing probabilistic inference in
a neural network is to do it through
sampling no more technically Markov
chain Monte Carlo sampling is one of
this two major algorithmic approaches
toward sampling which works in principle
for arbitrary complex distribution and
the method is simply you'll get it you
generate a few samples from this Markov
chain assuming it's already at this
stage distribution are close to this and
then you do some simple computation on
these samples that you have drawn rather
than doing belief propagation and other
no kind of algorithmic deterministic
computation procedures and then finally
I my fight excited about know this class
a problem solving constraint
satisfaction problems which I see much
too little address in kind of too little
address in in work on in theoretical
neuroscience them
and so then I think you all are familiar
with one particular type of Markov chain
if you ever came close to a diffusional
Network literature you know they are the
so-called pulsar machines physicist las
love them no they're really not so
equivalent to this Ising model stone and
so this is something which has nothing
to this spike in the runs right so this
artificial neurons each of them gives at
any moment in time a binary output 0 or
1 and then this know when unit is
allowed to switch then it goes to the
state 1 with a certain probability which
is sigmoid of this weighted sum of the
states of the other units in the back in
this network and its own bias then so
therefore this is no one needs then a
schedule so typically no there is a
overall schedule in banner flies buzzing
machines in artificial neural networks
there at every morning time exactly one
unit is allowed to switch you can also
in principle use awesome kunis version
of balsa machine although is more rarely
considered but this is closer not to
this kind of no models that I'm going to
discuss briefly so therefore now when
you have travel n units in a balsa
machine the state of the balsa machine
can be characterized a particular time
point by a bit work the simply of length
and this tells everything about know the
current state of the machine then and
now you can ask that when you look at
station distributions of balsa machines
know which know if you want to have a
nice Theory have somatic weights then
every distribution of a binary random
variables with at most second order
dependency is the states and resolution
of some balsa machine so they have some
kind of no-goodnik kind of
representative power in terms of
representing distributions then one can
trivially show that if you allow a self
also to add hidden units the balls
machine
if you allow yourself to add hidden
units to balls a machine you can even
represent distributions no over discrete
values with higher-order dependency so
this is not really now kind of a strict
limit then and then also know the
dynamics of our machine is no use then
also known and work in through computer
science no for MCMC sampling because no
this sampling amounts to keep simply
ignore one of the simplest common forms
of sampling so the birther machine is a
nice kind of comparison partners from
the world of computer science to now
stochastic neural networks and so the
question that I want to discuss know
what is possible relationships between
Esther of spiking neurons with noise and
buzzer machines and in order to make
such a relation you need to have some
way of translating spikes in continuous
time to kind of bit vectors and you
simply take now convention that whenever
a neuron spikes it sets the
corresponding variable for a short time
spent how to value one and then it drops
back to zero then and so this is
actually a kind of suggestion of
translating kind of spikes in continuous
time into bits which has been proposed
and it's analyzed know in the
experimental integer signal of the spec
I said I'll paper from the future lab
we're here no times in this is state and
our sample data time goes in this
direction will they have time bins and
then for each neuron that spikes here no
they put down here one and the other
ones are zero then right so this is not
the same way of kind of relating spikes
in continuous time to bit vectors of
course here the choice of this time
Benes arbiter right and you get other
results then some one should not dwell
on this then the bins in time correspond
to the time that spike
turns the value from zero to one is that
the same thing you don't have to do this
then I think you just know it gives you
a different kind of no certainly it
changes their bit vectors right you
might want to choose it but no since
they come in kind of no not periodically
no at this at the beginning of this time
being here right now so therefore this
can be chosen independently I think that
the Siri doesn't care so much as we see
in a moment by the way so this is
something if you want to make sense out
of this little bit know from the
perspective neurophysiology you could
view this to the duration of an epsp
because this is the time length no true
in which no other neurons no know that
there was a spike then right and ideally
therefore this theory only works really
well even now look at the links
rigorously if you would have epsps we
truly have a kind of a rectangular shape
know that they go up stay up and then
drop down then rather than having an
alpha shape or some other shape
I would also know to mention here know
that this is really a very nice result
this other papers from the group no
matter lingual Phillip I think they were
the first no neuroscientists I have seen
which surely took this idea seriously
that biological networks of neurons in
the brain they really encode probability
distributions and so this is the way I
know the right way to decode information
which they're containing rather they're
saying no they're container kind of
vectors or patterns or server in a few
of them as encoding distributions then
and suggest no for other reasons not
yours Tenenbaum and other cognitive
scientists have already for a long time
proposed that the brain actually stores
information the form of probability
distributions rather than memories or
upfield attractor networks or so and I
think this is not an idea which snow is
attractive from various points of view
computation points of view but also know
from the perspective of cognitive
science them so now even Oh uses no such
no theoretical no link between networks
of spiking neurons and where you now
also can kind of denote the state set at
any moment in time by particular of leg
and the question arises which
distributions can be represented or even
learned by networks of spiking neurons
there right and so there are no the
known results that in principle when
baits are symmetric
you can if you use idealized neural
models then which had no sketch here
then you can represent in this network
spiking neurons exactly the same
stations abuse isn't a policy machine
which has the same weight vector and
biases
so in some sense in that sense the
expressive power of these spiky neural
networks is exactly the same as a pasta
machine then and then also now as I
would expect then also know if you allow
them automatic baits also no hidden
neurons you can represent also quite
arbitrary distribution in networks of
spike in neurons then so from that
perspective I think that once you see
that by really not taking north networks
partners with noise seriously not as a
defective deterministic computational
model but as a genuine some kind of to
hosta computational models they have
something good to say in favor of them
so by the way now but man when users see
in a relatively standard norm newer
model where you have a membrane
potential which is the weighted sum of
EPS piece and then the instantaneous
firing probability is no the exponent of
this no membrane potential so this is
something which has been fitted also to
experimental data it's it's I think in a
reasonable good simple model for a
biological spike in neurons and as I
mentioned here the main defect is if you
want to have in a rigorous theory you
have to demand that this EPS piece they
don't decay gracefully but they stay up
and then drop down then but in
simulations one sees that quite similar
results no hold now if you use other
shapes of EPS piece but then you early
off from theory and no I don't know any
theory which supports this kind of more
biological common shapes of epsps them
so symmetric ways I can imagine
the network overall settles into sort of
I mean in a hopfield network it would
settle into one pattern but because of
the statistic process that will probably
settle into a distribution that is
centered around one of these or several
of these items that would be in the
hopper that works table states well if
you have a symmetric connections and
typically your limit cycles and you're
drifting distribution etc so what so
what's the notion of a probability
distribution so it's actually even a
further kind of symmetric but it's no
least number also the exam that we
consider you don't really have know that
this know has to have no 17 modes and
all the states in one of these modes so
even though sticks there right it's all
this time travels around so the
station's abuser just tells you if
you'll stand back and look for a long
time what fraction of the time the
network was in a particular state then
you have a certain probability which is
given by the stage distribution then but
it doesn't tell you anything about no
certain simple trajectories or so right
now it's cruises round all over the
place then oscillation is an interesting
aspect now I think I come back to this
then because I think man can argue that
even know takes know some data on the
role of bigger oscillations in the brain
seriously they might support this
computation with sampling but here at
the moment I'm still know kind of in the
theoretical sky that I'm a kind of
stepping down one step after another
okay so I think no one singles in a
wideband sure that learning I think no
even no wants to know pursue this
interesting hypothesis that nor be an n
snob which are always used as
abbreviation for networks of neurons in
the brain
use know is the knowledge space no
station C bution the question is which
needs distributions can they also learn
then right and how they can learn this
and so we see here again situation that
you know ready to make some
idealizations than deviate no some
aspects of no kind of diversity of
neural models
then in principle you can argue that no
net with respect nodes can actually
learn just from seeing examples of some
unknown distribution peace can kind of
form an internal model and then
reproduce as destination distribution a
kind of a learned version of this
external distribution P star then so
this is sampling which I want to only
quickly know sketch the idea to you how
to think about this in terms of know
kind of the models that it requires to
really realize this so assume now this
is now an external distribution generate
samples and assume it's no these are a
bit vectors itself is a big vector and
assume now this is given as a population
for each I mean for each coordinate you
have two neurons and bonfires for one
and the other one for value 0 then right
now just as simple population coding so
this is now the examples which are given
to this network and then what it would
be sufficient if you have then for each
random variable here the superscript K
then one model which tries to estimate
what is the dependence of this variable
by K on other variables or sufficiently
on the random variables in its Markov
blanket then and so then in principle
you can construct now networks of
spiking neurons which can learn or
approximate at least this conditional
distribution table just from seeing no
kind of input spikes and no kind of also
the spikes for this by K then so simply
for observing possibly this kind of no
patterns know the assignment or value to
random variable spike or no spike if
it's population coding in which of these
two neurons know for this two values
spike in terms of know the population
coding for the current values of this
variables in the Markov blanket then and
so what it turns out in principle if you
have a neurons which face one hidden
layer and all spike in neurons and you
assume a CDP no spike timing-dependent
plasticity takes place only in this
layer you can know according to theory
approximate this conditional conditional
table then dependents of this variable
by K on the red number bits in this
Markov blanket and even uses a kind of
no LS form of SDP one can even apply in
a powerful tools from theory no
expectation maximization and I think
that's interesting to see that here
noticed elasticity of the network model
become surely essential not to carry out
this on that approximation of e M
because no the e step is really kind of
realized through taking a sample from
this distribution then and so for this
now you need this kind of stochastic
step so this similarly the e step is no
you give an input some neuron fires here
this is a realization of the east step
then no kind of know the one which snuff
then bins you know this competition then
can also carried out a CDP then and so
this is then the M step of this online
diem approximation and so this way one
can prove know that some approximation
to this given distribution takes place
then and then there's also theory around
then for computation in network of
spiking neurons which saves in principle
if this happens no independent in all
these models for each random variable by
K then then altogether no this model
produced an approximation to this no
given distribution just from this
examples then and I don't want to go too
much into details here but and also not
want to point out now this is something
which requires not to be close to the
theory it requires abstraction you can't
take no vanilla newer models no from
Dellen a database then but you need to
have no kind of simplified neural models
then I will come back later to this then
and we will always have this trade-off
right we want to have nice theory and
nice you know theorems we need to have
more simpler models then typically and
so here now be at the moment very far on
this side of having nice theory but also
having strongly simplified models but a
sillas tells us also something that a
principle network of spiking neurons
cannot only Express powerful
distribution or possibly also learn
distribution right and
so this is also type of learning which
doesn't require any back propagation or
other things which is salmon or kind of
foreign to biological neural networks
I would also quickly know scheduled show
you this result if you just have it know
a new kind of simpler problem you just
have a network of spiking neurons and
you give it here bunch an input stream
here say of 100 neurons there to this
you know in this case I think six
neurons there and occasionally this
mother kind of frozen Poisson patterns
into this you like the green pattern
cars here and here but each time
superimposed by new spikes you find that
after a while
each of these neurons in this competing
pool specialises for one of these
patterns like this neuron number one
only fires when this green pattern
occurs and then here also again when
this green pattern occurs then so this
is an automated unsupervised learning
mechanism which is not supported by the
same idealized version of SDP and also
nor theoretically know by stochastic or
9:00 a.m. and this previous no more
complex model kind of no use this as a
kind of a small atomic model for
learning then and I think what we need
is more than kind of no paradigms for
unsupervised learning also networks of
spiking neurons now going into more and
more realistic no assumptions about know
the network its diversity and synaptic
plasticity but I will come back to this
later then another interesting type of
computation that can be carried out if
you have a kind of noisy computation
system is no solving problem solving and
so for example cleaning tasks and I'm
really like quite a bit you know one
result no which is known by logic result
from nature paper 2013 where rodent was
sitting at some place not at its home
location but it was thinking about
moving home then so you know this one
can decoded this is the point here this
triangle indicates where the rodent is
sitting and which direction is looking
like he is looking here then and the X
home position is indicated here and so
these are kind of recordings from area
CA one so you can decode no you know
what place is currently represented by
the CA one activity and so this is
already decoding of the action of CA one
activity in terms of the place which is
encoded by this and when CN or this what
the data suggest then know that here but
see you know episodes know about hundred
millisecond long with already sitting
here and apparently thinking about going
to the home location or it's sitting
here and thinking about the home
location there so NC yeah this is
something which could be viewed as
rudimentary planning thence it's not
something where you process kind of
sensor input but you you plan know what
to do next then and this is just I think
an extremely simple instance of a
consensus section problem that brains
have to solve all the time then both not
only for motor planning but also for the
sensory processing you know that the
world is full of ambiguous sensory
inputs right and you need to arrive at
the most likely solution then in the end
then and so the general question is I
think we should know dress and is know
particularly know from the perspective
of computer science how can biological
neural network solve constraint
satisfaction problems so I think it's
something which is really in our
interesting question because these
typically are hard
computational problems even from the
perspective of computation complexity
and brains have to solve this problem
then and I think we should come up with
more ideas how this can take place then
and the principle even looks at
idealized models know their ways of
doing this and so even though it was
demonstrated know for the Traveling
Salesman problem then when you where you
can represent this by in principle the
problem and looking for solution by
having for each time step of the tour to
given cities snow by one minute a call
circuit so which and each will I take
all circuits contains for each city one
neuron there and so therefore if this
neuron fires or wins this competition it
means at this time point you consider
the tour where this second city is
visited at this time point
and so therefore when you let this
network around then it considers all
types of possible to us to this given
set of cities so he has demonstrated for
instance of 38 citizen and then so we
see here now also no online running for
each unit egg oil circle like this one
here which is responsible for time step
15 you see it considers no different no
cities to be in a time step 15 and so
this is overall know kind of the
performance over the oil Network on
average then and when sees in terms of
what is the cost of the tour and Mencius
no it becomes up with no better and
better to us in the long run then and so
therefore fancier simply because in
principle network spike neurons has the
capability to do know about everything
the bolsa machine can do it can also
solve constraint satisfaction problem in
the same way as it has been proposed in
a long time ago already for both some
machines one interesting aspect is not
which we don't fully understand yet is
actually that if you compare now here
this kind of solution button on the
solution speed of spiking neurons and
bolts and machines even if you look at
these two types of networks which have
accepted the same statements abusin that
turns out that spike in neural networks
typically arrive fast at good solutions
then and so this new kind of no relies
on this certain effect that even if you
have two networks which have the same
station say bution they may divide up
the fractions of time that they spend in
particular state in a different ways
then and so the spike in neural networks
tend to divide them up that even if one
state is very good they kind of just
revisit this state of rather than
staying a long time at the state when
they are there so this is now something
which just comes from this translating
enough states in to spike in neural
networks and I'm not sure whether one
can make out of this but like in
principle idea that we also should think
about the kind of noisy brain networks
whether possibly they are designed to
solve constraint satisfaction problems
faster and not arbitrary constraints as
very important satisfaction problem
probably not the Traveling Salesman
problem but just the types of problems
the organism needs to solve
no to survive them and so therefore we
should think about really brain
construction network construct in terms
of supporting kind of no finding certain
types of solutions fast through sampling
then which means know that it doesn't
have to work for every stage
distribution but also for sums with
those which occur in the real world and
so I came back to this later then when I
look at more kind of realistic
constraints yeah
mmm you only looked at those switch
cameras and represented by both sir
machines so I think it's a very good
question then and maybe to construct nor
look at no particular types of networks
particular sir maybe I can only look at
this and say this is zoomed that you
have no homogeneous neurons right now
maybe you can construct now a neural
network using diverse types of neurons
right there some neurons like to fire
more than other neurons in order to
support particular types of constraint
satisfaction problem solution I think
this would be wonderful
kind of idea but ralina would kind of
know I think advance our thinking at
least then yeah just you want to know
show that know some experimental
evidence from neuroscience that actually
brains do sampling and so one of the
earliest personal from the work of
Nicolas Logothetis then where they
recorded know why the monkey was looking
at an ambiguous visual stimulus and they
had a rapport with the lever which of
this two stimuli they currently
perceived they found no the switch in
perception is accompanied by switching
firing red states and particular higher
brain areas which the 90% of the firing
rate know in terms of the current
percept there is no lower kind of no
primary areas here only 20% of the
neurons no go along with the percept and
I find this interesting because this
really is kind of only the internal
processing right now the stimulus
doesn't change at all then it's only the
percept this changes right but Betsey's
according to the data of the large parts
of the brain putting the higher breaths
of the brain normally no kind of switch
they stayed according to the percept and
rather than being kind of enslaved by
the current sensory input and and so on
Syria this potential of sampling I think
number of you are kind of normal work on
hippocampus and so there's a well-known
example they are then from the Mosel
Epton where they put no rodent into
uncertainty whether I was currently in
the blue or the red environment which
was no origin indicated by actually
different no background lighting then
and then been there then put know this
road and into a situation where
wasn't quite sure in which of this
environment it was then they recorded
over time then know kind of what is the
percept at the beach environment this
road and currently Boston so here it was
for for tether cycles it thought it was
in the blue environment then for 2 theta
cycles it was the red environment and
then again for 5 in the blue environment
and no they point out now that one
doesn't find any tether cycles no where
you find a little bit no here's a tiny
little bit be within the same theta
cycle there's evidence that they think
that they're both in the red and in the
red blows in the blue and in the red
environment right so it's really
sampling in a it doesn't know PPO and
any theta cycle the probability of being
in a certain environment but it gives
you one of these two environments and
right and just from the frequency of
being in a particular guest environment
you can maybe the brain can infer know
which is the most likely of this one's
so this is one that's evidence from the
hippocampus there was no recently also
actually here from UC Berkeley from the
valleys lab very nice paper that in the
orbital frontal cortex so an area where
kind of the values of particular choices
are represented that been there had
experiments where they call it from many
neurons simultaneously which is
necessary in order to guess what our
network states then right so this is
only possible when you can do
simultaneous recording for many neurons
and then they put no the monkey in
iteration where they could choose number
two between two different reports then
they were all kind of no different juice
rewards but some no work if more of them
and some they liked more than others so
it was non-trivial choice then and then
during the time now there was a certain
delay where they had a deliberate which
of these two things they're like puzzle
rewards are like more than the truth we
bought it went through different network
states indicated here by blue or red
curve being higher the red is the choice
which was actually chosen in the end and
this blue is the choice which was
rejected in the end and you see you know
it goes forth and back no initially no
the blue was winning and then later to
theory the actual decision the red
choice was winning here it
no.4 then back even here it went very
close to the end no coming back to the
blue one but in the end the red was
chosen and so they argue that in the end
no the algorithm or the the information
encoding in the orbitofrontal cortex
kind of is consistent with the
prediction from MCMC sampling because
there you will choose and this kind of
no choice which would be kind of
represented more often by this network
states then and you see here that the
chosen option occurs on average somewhat
more frequently than the unchosen option
then unless these also no coming back to
I think no the question about hasta
lations
and kind of no sampling that in
principle here you see her no there is
not a strict rhythm there right now you
see no these are 400 milliseconds so you
have no states which are entertained for
somewhere between I don't know 30 and
goes to 100 or so milliseconds right so
one doesn't see a strict timing there
but there's a certain rhythm there which
apparently allows this to switch states
which is I think an non-trivial task
actually for network in order to do
sampling you should avoid the two kind
of samples really kind of mix up in an
undesired way then right you don't want
to have a fusion of two popular states
then that you want to have unpopular
States or another populous there's no
fusion of two so therefore an offer to
do no rigorous sampling no there must be
some mechanism for this and this may be
also know some inhibitor sub networks or
other kind of know part of this ugly
parts of pollution neural networks might
also support this type of sampling and
Mencius is a type of computation
operation which will would never have
thought of if we just think no the
animal has to decide no weather no
orientations upwards or kind of no
horizontal right so they're quite
different computations carrying out in
the brain which require quite different
no computation operations then
and find a good solution to the
constraint optimization problem faster
than a Boltzmann machine is they do you
have any good intuition for why a
spiking or network setup sells fast
yeah someone has a principle know is
intuition but also it's something which
I think I wouldn't suggest really is
something which takes really place in
brains then at the moment I just sees as
a theory results and the reason is and
that imprints they have a ball so
machine it can stay in a state as long
as it wants to when you have a spike in
neural networks no it can only maximally
stay for time spent out within the same
state and because as soon as no
something has spiked and then the
spiking kind of sensitivity peraud is
fallen off then it has to change the
state so both the spike and kind of no
spike how units of time ago changed the
state and so we have forced state
changes all the time in the spike in
neural networks principally about then
you would revisit it and but no one
finds and actually I think know that
they use some a different strategy
because no good point here the effect
appearance force is no kind of note to
go to a new state and they may go back
to the same part two different ones and
so therefore spike neural networks are
more jumpy in there kind of sampling
varus no policy machine may find a good
solution and stay there now farm is kind
of time units right best back neurons
just revisit this often which means on
the other hand them on average they come
earlier to kind of a good solution but
just because they jump around so much I
don't base time in spending a lot of
time in a particular state and I think
no one problem go just from the
computational modeling perspective which
but also has to consider when takes the
sampling perspective for computation
seriously that here with I think nobody
has totally about the way in the such
networks how they can how this network
can hold on now to good state and right
or remember previously found no
reasonable code states then so there's a
additional combat computational overhead
and circuit overhead which is needed
truly use no sampling right now this is
just the heart of the same thing
machinery
but other know kind of no architectures
are needed for this and I have no idea
now how this works then there must be
some kind of no collection of evidence
and also holding on to particular states
so this for this one should know provide
good ideas then yeah yeah in this
medical model yeah it's related to is
quite arbitrary Tao then which is
related somehow to the membrane time
constant if you want to and then he just
pointed out no biological brain networks
use their own kind of no sampling rate
right which is no slow much slower than
but it still works but yes I have to
come to an end of the first let's see
whether so have you know kind of know
written down a few references actually
the slides of my talk you can find on my
web page although no finding my web page
has become more difficult because my
university has changed now to kind of
standard web pages so if you find my
standard home page where the mounts and
the background and then go to
publications on top of this I have here
another PDF of this talk then
and so then no here no there's a more
recent review paper of the people I
mentioned before metalingual visa and
Becca's about know this idea of sampling
really in involution neural networks and
then they also had no other theoretical
work nor multilingual slip on sampling
hamiltonian sampling has been considered
and then you know marginalize discretion
and really dealing computation with
probabilities probably the inference
they of course also other models which
have been proposed how networks of
neurons can carry out publicity
inference right which is not about same
thing but with some form of belief
propagation so this is a nice review
which discusses know some of these
options or Alex bujji's work nor gives
you references for this
yes maybe I think let's see this is it
yeah so this is I think a good no any
point for the first hour so they a lot
of loose or open question so as I
mentioned I think now thinking about now
how brain networks can solve constraint
satisfaction problem I think is a really
good problem and so I just know sketched
somewhat naive no Theory driven method
how they can do this so we have to come
up with a solution ideas which are
closer to record the data and as a see
know they are recorded data which seemed
to suggest brain networks to solve
problems through sampling then example
the constraint satisfaction problem that
you think a brain needs to solve yeah
like I think know this going home then
for the rodent right and they had also
in the same paper actually not going
home but going to another location does
path planning of us so is in principle
simple planning problem constraint
satisfaction problem right but also all
kinds of things right now because you
just interpret is ambiguous stimulus
because you have background knowledge
you want this and but you have this
other conflicting evidence right no now
you have to make sense out of these
conflicting evidence and one way of
formulating this also is a constraint
satisfaction problem although not other
need type now is usually considered into
your computer science and I think no but
really important about this type of task
is that visually computational issues
it's not where the brain network is
driven by the sensor input right it
really has to come up with something
like fantasy imagination or so create
creativity and I think one can approach
these types of no brain capabilities
also with these types of models and as I
mentioned it's an open question
interesting about question whether the
en ends have other methods besides to
hostak sampling for publishing inference
I mention early the principal has to
think also about new kind of the
overhead architecture how can brain
network recognize that a proposed
solution is a good reasonable solution
and maybe cache it then for later use
then then there is this question how can
different samples of a B and n be
separate in time
then possibly through some background
oscillation or some other way there kind
of inhibition simply shuts down the
current search then and then let's
restart the network then then I quickly
mention early that all these models that
I mentioned earlier based on homogeneous
models for neurons and synapses which is
not the way how pian ends are
constructed and so I think it would be
wonderful example not to come up and
over something where you construct even
now neurons which have different
preferred firing rates different other
properties know different types of
inhibitory networks which can do certain
kind of constraint sampling tasks very
efficiently I think this would be very
nice new computational paradigm then and
then in the end also I think no one
defect with this no theory about no
relating SN ends to be an ends that
their random variable is represented in
the network experiments by a single
spike in neurons and I don't think that
their brain chooses this kind of coding
solitaries probably uses an assembly of
neurons and also all this data suggests
is right so this is now rethinking nor
really how sampling can take place in
terms of nor assemblies being switched
on and often so this would be kind of
close at the biological reality then to
resolving constraint satisfaction
problem and it would also be no more I
think with the timing that we have seen
it the simple changes maybe every 80
millisecond or so right now this would
be a time spent for activating assembly
and then deactivating it also so this is
would be very nice if you have can
produce such models particular also
produce theory support for such models
of this type of to hostak sampling okay
it's three o'clock or maybe other
question you bring all these subsystems
they have very characteristic
architecture ascent and circuits and so
as my questions about the cortex you
think the cortex is going to be have
sort of bummed and one episodes
architecture like attractors and then
all the examples that you pose are they
going to be happy
melded into this so grandmother way of
looking at things or do you think we do
you think that it's somehow there's many
Polly's circuits and problems are gonna
have to be sort of folded in there like
so many exciting question yeah so I
think considering how much annuity I
think we be seen already know just if
you sing naively brain solving no
constraints intersection problem there
needs four different kind of computation
operations which may be really know we
realized through different networks then
right when sees actually I think the
brain data kind of suggests a particular
kind of subset of brain areas which are
engaged in sampling which are the ones
which are active in spontaneous activity
those which are go down when you really
know activated tasks and so these are
the apparently the same brain networks
which I engage not growing dreaming or
something right for imagination or so so
they seem to be specialized networks
which no kind of know if at all carry
out such no search or imagination or
sampling then and yeah in higher areas
in the cortex and sector so I had no
kind of this default Network ideas and
and others and so they're either near
like v1 probably shouldn't sample so
much it should really not try to come up
with one solution right and not with
many solutions then right so therefore I
think no they're different computational
needs in real-time computing using
sampling right and so therefore
different brain networks may be
specialized for supporting these
different types of computations
[Applause]